bon le mec à la compta les chiffres là
c'est n'importe quoi sa part clairement
rang cacahuètes mais détends toi viens
on va se voir un petit pois pas le
travail pardon je te rappelle que demain
à 9h générer une courte chronique juste
un petit verre sont moins grandes jamais
tard amorison soirées étudiantes ou une
soirée vidéo
alors moi perso si je peux donner mon
avis je suis clairement hyper chaud pour
sortir et me défoncer la gueule
donc je dis tu viens mercredi du bien ou
pas ah bon mais je peux pas moi je
m'occupe des enfants comme d'hab
moi je suis chalet est toujours là a
appelé mardi à apa lundi que tu sais
comment il est nul mais travail reprend
le sumo le sol et y aller on commence à
lundi la sarre avec toulalan même jeté
les jeux pour viens avec nous enfin moi
je rentre vers 23h minuit dans ça vous
dérange pas sinon demain je suis fait
mal pas faux mais c'est moi quoi lundi
laisse tomber tes déprimant j'appelle
dimanche dimanche
ainsi parlait que de dire super à zogona
pure à s'amuser ah ouais donc le mec est
coincé du cul quoi on dirait mardi
cervelas espèce deux jours de week-end
excusez moi mais du choc d'affilée de
votre cas c'est pas trop ma vision de
l'amusement maintenant je me sens hyper
mal j'ai envie de dégobiller enfin temps
ci travaille tout le temps à 14h c'est
un peu normal que tu es une mauvaise
hygiène de vie aux excuses nous mais
nous les dimanches on est des gens
détendus
ouais nous on se réveille tard on glande
un peu et alors ça pose problème je
t'arrête tout de suite mon loulou on
n'est pas tous pareils à quoi par
exemple ce matin je me suis réveillé à
7h petit jus d'orange pressé un petit
bisou à mes enfants
et là tels que tu me vois je suis en
train de jogging ça c'est le signal qui
m'a dit que je souhaite sur une marche
rapide
à bientôt parce que nous démange parfait
moi j'ajuste prévu un brunch et et
téléfoot et un jogging osait enfin
mettre un jogging t quoi tu me dégoûtes
franchement tu es pas digne et à jour du
week-end ok les mecs vous avez gagné tu
sais quoi j'ai prendre ma douche et
j'arrive
et les hanches toi qu'à la belle vie te
rappelles toi pour demain on les gagne à
lundi qui est en train de me déprimer la
vie c'est une réalité les mecs c'est
tout c'est quoi moi j'ai foutu ma
couette je regardais une série je vais
manger des sushis je sais pas non plus
rien sinon je travaille tout le temps et
je suis heureux d'ailleurs comme on dit
le travail c'est la santé oms avait un
petit peu tes larmes sorte on est dans
du cul et métaux au boulot parce que
j'ai carrément changé d'avis je suis
totalement chaud pour aller en club on y
va ou pas aller à dakar donc samedi
dimanche et mardi toute l'histoire et
moi je suis nul hemus travailler voilà
ma vie ces trous de l'aplomb berder
carrément mieux en fait je suis avec
vous west bike shop ou alors c'est à
dire que tu proviens terme est de voir
ben on ne travaille pas aujourd'hui tête
voire on peut clairement dire que on
s'en bat les couilles
ouais
ah ouais génial merci les mecs à les
regretter ou bien pendue occupent des
petits morveux super alors la recette de
la pâte à sel c'est simple c'est de la
farine et de l'eau super les vacances
scolaires super grosse éclater sa volée
mais avec attend peut être un peu
solidaires
donc c'est toute l'année que me l'étape
et j'ai une île et si on faisait un peu
de devoir reprendre un peu d'avancé bon
les fera dimanche soir à la dernière
seconde comme d'hab et auprès de son
beau alors parce qu'après tout on re
boss c'est tout on est bien on est bien
ouais c'est bon non celle de gages à m
bon on s'en fout